لقد دعوت إلى تجريد رباعي من
استضافة كأس العالم 2022 إذا
ثبتت إدانته بارتكاب انتهاكات للأخلاقيات ،
هل رأيت أي دليل
رشيق مصر إن شاء الله رقم
مطبخ Elana ذهبت إلى المركز في قلعة
Allen frosya Humber Vicky سأرى
أنت وشيريل حصلت على عرض عام 2026
في تغريدة في وقت سابق من هذا العام قلت إن
المغرب كان مخطئًا في عدم وقوفه إلى جانب
المملكة العربية السعودية في القط ، حيث تشير الأزمة إلى
أن بلدك لن يصوت لصالح
محاولة المغرب لاستضافة كأس العالم.
الموقف يا سيدي لم
يكن لديه ماسالا يتذكره أبدًا مثل
عضو لوبي أو العام الذي دخان فيه لين
عندما طورت قصة تفتقر إليه
ماسالا هام أمريكا ، هل ندرس حول
كوليبار جلوريا الرومانسية المثالية أمريكي دولا حليفة
آدم آل خليفة آنا سوكولوف أطلق النار على
رجل نبيل  مع السعودية وملكة جمال
فال هوم تور ، كان لدى الخروف ريكا
لعنة قليلة ويمارس الجنس مع المد والجزر
Amriki المقدس ، البلطي لعنة
الشكل الزائدي ، أعني ذرة فعلية في Eastham
touch عبر Cassadine سألني عن ذلك
فام ريكا
حسنًا ، لقد اتخذت محكمة استنتاجية ، وضع القليل من
الألمانية هنا إذا كان Lemieux غلاية على ما هو
خالد عبد الله عصابة المد والجزر ، لذا فأنت
تخبرني أنك ستدعم الولايات المتحدة.
فعلت المكسيك كندا بت أكيرا ويكي القرد
العظيم ماريو سوتو